[Música]
hola
yo vengo de un país donde antes la
comida aún daba nos faltaba a nadie
donde los restaurantes eran lugares de
lujo de excesos llenos de cultura ya que
este país siendo venezuela en qué
estamos hablando
es un país donde vinieron demasiados
emigrantes y nos llenaron de riquezas
culturales de arte
de ideas yo soy hijo de extranjeros me
siento menos que nadie
e
siento que toda esta información me hizo
tomar la decisión de ser chef
todas las experiencias que viví en los
restaurantes de carga acá abajo de
venezuela
me llenaron de ganas de vivir ese
prestigio que tenían los chefs en estos
restaurantes
empecé a buscar cómo era la manera de
llegar a ser chef cocinando en casa
haciendo infinidad de recetas
malas todas
se lo puedo asegurar era terrible
les cuento algo cuando estaba en quinto
año de bachillerato en paralelo empecé a
estudiar en una escuela que se llama
seca
y ahí
mi camino para ir mi camino de cocinar
al final de este curso uno presenta un
examen para hacer el curso largo de
cocina
en el examen y uno de los chefs que iba
a tomarla
iba a tomar uno de los ingredientes para
saber qué era lo que estábamos cocinando
y agarro como un drama pastor y dije
nadie aquí es donde yo gano aquí es
donde yo digo eso es pasto porque tenía
agarrarlo resulta que era estragón dije
que era pasto y bueno como pueden ver
llegué a chef así que todos pueden
llegar a ser chef
en ese momento empecé a buscar otra
academia y me encontré con un mundo de
egos en el mundo de la cocina está llena
de egos como todas las carreras
donde nosotros los chef o los cocineros
porque en realidad la carrera de
cocinero
creemos que la gente debe comer
lo que nosotros pensamos que es correcto
y en ningún momento razonamos que la
gente es la que te exige lo que lo que
debes preparar
y bueno poco a poco fui entendiendo esta
guerra de egos a través de todos los
restaurantes que fui
trabajando o participando
y
me di cuenta que nada más no era nada
más inventar y decir bueno esto fui yo
primero el que el que creó este plato o
sea
yo creé este plato nosotros tenemos esa
mentira en la cabeza que yo fui el que
lo cree
yo fui el primero y no es así no no es
así entendí que es más allá es saber
también adaptar lo que fuiste
aprendiendo poco a poco en la historia
de tu carrera o de tu vida por digo de
tu vida porque también hay ingredientes
que reprobaba cuando era niño platos que
vi cuando era niño que después fui
adaptando a un mercado que fue
evolucionando como el venezolano
después de esto de entender las
sencillas de la gastronomía quitarme
todos los juegos y aprender a ser
humilde para aprender de lo que tú crees
que no saben nada de cocina cómo puede
ser una madre cómo puede ser un amigo o
alguien que no estudió gastronomía
empezar sobre todo especialmente en di
que también va de la mano con el
liderazgo
si tú no crean equipos de alto
rendimiento como lo son los solos de un
restaurante no vas a lograr nada porque
al final si tubo creas un plato por muy
sencillo que sea y tú no eres líder
nadie te lo va a repetir 100 200 o 1000
veces igual que tú porque al final tus
cocineros son la extensión de tus brazos
ok
después que entendía esto tuve la
oportunidad de ser chef de un
restaurante la temporada de un
restaurante que se llama barrio que
estará en mercedes tenía 23 años
me presentaron la cocina el restaurante
estaba casi quebrado en el momento que
se ha quebrado no llevaba una semana de
abierto hecho que está en ese momento
estaban devolviéndole los platos como
loco me llaman y me dice mira
necesitamos que te encargues esta cocina
y dije bueno chévere vamos vamos a
enfrentar este este reto
yo dije que si me lo podía por dentro
del cielo no sé que estoy haciendo es
eran 42 cocineros yo tenía 23 años y la
media edad que tenía los cocineros de
ese momento era más o menos de 30 a 50
años o sea para que me hicieran caso de
un tema
y ahí es donde entendí lo que era de
verdad crear equipo
y el equipo se crea que de manera que
confíen en ti en tu conocimiento
como crees eso demostrando demostrando
trascendiendo como enseñando
quitando t el ego
para que tú puedes a través de tu
sencillez y su humildad mostrar tus
conocimientos a otros
porque les cuento esto porque de esta
manera me construí para ser chef pero me
encuentro en otro problema que hoy en
día manejo un negocio de comida que
siendo un restaurante en un país con
hambre aquí viene lo complicado como
haces tú para que alguien cociné
sabiendo que esa persona no comió ese
día más el simple dato es cómo lo haces
dándole herramientas de mostrándole que
tú no nada más lo vas a alimentar de
mostrándole que tú lo que les va a dar
es herramientas para enfrentar este
problema enseñándoles
escuchándolos
creando equipo en este momento yo tengo
a carlos 142 personas manejamos dos
restaurantes en un país con hambre y
esto es complicado
saber que ellos deben trabajar en un
local de experiencia es decir un
mesonero tiene que llegar y sonreírle un
cliente todos los días todos los días
cuando esta persona tiene una infinidad
de problemas en sus casas
y esto como se logra nosotros en el
restaurante lola lo logramos de esta
manera primero hacemos dos charlas
diarias todos los días todos los días
del mundo hacemos dos charlas diarios
concientizar hacer entender que no están
perdiendo el tiempo
y con los cocineros
por lo menos tres veces por semana
para que le tomen el valor a lo que
están haciendo para que no crean que uno
no tiene ahí para que serían nada más en
venezuela sino para darles herramientas
para que ellos oferten a otros países
ellos lleven algo nuevo y confíen en
dónde están y quiénes son darles la
confianza y no se sientan menos porque
están pasando por algo tan complejo como
esta situación
les comento que
si ustedes tienen algún otro tipo de
carrera otro tipo de negocio lo mejor
que pueden hacer es delegar enseñar
trascender inmortalizarse es trascender
a través de la enseñanza es la única
manera en que se inmortalizó y eso lo
que le enseñamos nosotros a nuestros
muchachos
que entiendan que no nada más
es tener el prestigio de inmediato sino
también me queda gran
gran éxito un gran sacrificio y hacer
ver a la gente en este momento en esta
venezuela que esto es un gran gran
sacrificio para un gran éxito futuro
gracias
[Aplausos]